[Music]
previously
we saw that a couple of thoughts were
puzzling nora
and we mentioned that calculus was the
key to answer them
she wanted to know that when we drop a
ball how can we find its speed at an
instant
and while thinking about this she had
another strange thought
she was convinced that mathematically
the ball should
never reach the floor this thought has
puzzled many people for centuries
and it's called the xenos dichotomy
paradox
what are your thoughts about these
problems
there were two more interesting problems
we had discussed
let's say we're standing on a cliff then
what is the best way to throw a stone
such that it covers
maximum distance and the other problem
was
how can we find the area of any shape
especially
whose boundary is made up of curved
lines
we know that calculus gives us the
answer to all these problems
question is how first
we'll focus our attention on these three
problems
and for this problem the one for which
we need to find the angle at which to
throw the stone
we'll have to wait till we gain some
additional knowledge of calculus
let's move on to a new page and start
with this interesting thought
puzzling nora she thinks that
mathematically
the ball should never reach the floor as
the ball falls
it has to cover half of the distance
between its starting position and the
floor
then it has to cover half of the
remaining distance
then it has to cover the next half and
then the next half
and so on so the number of steps the
ball has to perform
never ends another way of saying it
is that there are infinite number of
steps the ball has to perform
beware of the term infinite always
remember
that infinite is not a number infinite
just means
something which never ends or something
that's limitless
now to perform each step the ball takes
some time
since the number of steps the ball has
to cover never ends
that is there are infinite number of
steps so nora thinks the ball should
never reach the floor
but we know that as we drop the ball it
reaches the floor in a few seconds
so where is the mistake in nora's logic
in order to know the time the ball takes
to reach the floor
we have to add all the individual time
periods taken
to perform the individual steps
but to find this we will have to add an
infinite number of terms
let's say we take our calculator out and
start adding these numbers
then our addition will go on and on and
we'll never finish
and as we go on adding the number the
sum will get
bigger and bigger that's it
as the ball continues to cover the
successive steps
the total time taken by the ball will
keep on increasing
another way to say this is the ball will
take an infinite amount of time
to reach the floor but we know that this
isn't true
as its common knowledge that the ball
will reach the floor in a few seconds
it will be well defined number that
means
if we add all the time periods taken to
perform the individual steps
we should get a number as our answer
yes even though we can't mechanically
add the numbers
we can show that the sum of these
infinite numbers
is equal to a number to show this
we carry out a process known as taking
the limit
and this is the central idea that
calculus uses
to solve the problems we mentioned
to understand calculus we need to
understand the concept of limits first
which we will cover in the upcoming
parts
to understand this paradox let's keep
things simple
we know that as the ball is falling its
speed increases
but for simplicity let's assume the
speed of the ball to be constant
of course we will get the answer even if
we take the ball speed to be increasing
but it will be a little bit complicated
so let's say the ball falls with a
constant speed
of half a meter per second in reality
the ball speed will be more than this
but we want to keep it simple
with this beat we know that the ball
will take just two seconds to cover the
distance
of one meter and reach the floor
so let's see how much time the ball
takes to cover these
individual steps
the time required to cover the first
half of a meter
will be one second then to cover the
next one-fourth of the meter
it will take half a second then to cover
the next one-eighth of the meter
it will be one-fourth of a second and so
on
so did you observe an interesting thing
after some steps the time taken to
complete the subsequent steps
will be very very small so as the ball
completes the successive steps
the time taken by it to perform the next
step will get
closer and closer to zero this is an
important concept
it's getting closer to a definite number
but remember it will not be zero
each step requires some time however
negligible it may be
we know that the ball takes two seconds
to reach the floor
now we can show that if we add all these
values of time
taken by the ball to perform each step
the sum will
never exceed two and will actually be
equal to 2.
before we prove this let me give you
another example
consider this square let's say the
length of each of its side
is 1 meter then we know that its area
will be one square meter
now let's divide or split this area as
we did with the motion of the ball
first we divide the area into two halves
then we take one of the two halves and
further divide it into two halves
so what we get is two quarters of the
square
now we take one of the quarters and
again divide it into two halves
and we keep repeating this process
what's happening here
we will realize that this is also a
never-ending process
but even though it's a never-ending
process
we know that the area of the square
which is one square meter
will be equal to the sum of the areas of
these parts
so we see that the sum of these infinite
terms is equal to one
which is a definite number we can't
manually add all these terms
but their sum turns out to be one
now as we go on dividing the square the
area of its part gets smaller
and smaller they get so small that their
area is very very close to zero but not
zero
but because these parts as a whole make
up the square
the sum of their areas cannot be greater
than one
so if we keep on adding the areas of
these parts
their sum will approach one the word
approach
is very important here anyway
i'm not sure if you've realized but you
almost have an answer for the sum of the
time period taken by the ball
to reach the flow look at the expression
we had for the time taken by the ball
to reach the floor and look at this
expression we have
for the parts of a square now if we add
one to this set of numbers
it becomes the same as this expression
so if we add 1 to both sides here we get
the sum of these values
as 2. let me recap
on the right hand side of this equality
we have these numbers
which are the same as the time taken by
the ball to cover
each step and we get the addition of
these
infinite terms to be 2 which is exactly
the time taken by the ball
to reach the floor so nora understood
where she went wrong with her logic
she assumed that the total time the ball
will take to cover these
infinite steps will be infinite
remember what we mean by infinite hair
it means
something that never ends
now let's look at a quick demonstration
so that you understand it better
this is the expression we found for the
total time taken by the ball
to reach the floor right now let's try
to find the cumulative time taken by the
ball
to reach the floor for each step
for example after two steps the time
taken by the ball
will be one second plus half a second
and that's equal to 1.5
seconds similarly after three steps
the total time taken by the ball will be
1.75 seconds
if we continue this for other steps we
see
that the total time taken will get
closer and closer to two seconds
as the ball covers the successive steps
the time taken by it to cover
each step is very very small so
even if we continue adding many time
periods the total time
will never exceed 2 seconds the total
time taken
will just get closer and closer to 2
seconds
this is an example to understand the
idea of the limit process
we can't find the answer to the sum of
infinite terms of numbers
but if we keep on adding successive
steps we see
that the sum approaches our number with
this
nora is not confused anymore we see that
if we divide the motion of the ball
into an infinite number of steps it
seems that it will take
infinite time to cover these steps but
we can show
that as we add the time periods taken in
each step
the total time taken by the ball gets
closer and closer to a definite number
it's similar for the distance the ball
covered too
we had seen how the distance was split
into infinite parts
it doesn't mean the distance is infinite
the sum of these distances will approach
1 meter
and guess what through this limit
process
we can also find the instantaneous speed
of the ball
if you remember this was another
question that nora had
we will discuss it in the next part see
you there